hey guys it is Friday which means I'm
here to get you Oh caught up on this
week's news here's what's been happening
first up the Death Star deal Z star wars
battlefront arrived this week 2 season
pass owners the Death Star DLC includes
five new maps the battle station mode as
well as new weapons and star cards
you'll also have access to the new hero
characters Chewbacca and bask alongside
the dlc release came an update for all
players which includes bug fixes a
weapon changes and balancing alterations
for hero abilities and equipment the
level cap has also been kicked up from
70 to 90 and everyone is getting new
free costumes for the full patch notes
check out our story on site after many
years Blizzard is planning to do away
with the battlenet name the battlenet
services will all remain the same but
the name is changing to align more with
their other services which are called
the blizzard streaming and Blizzard
voice elicits a battlenet causes issues
in that it's a single name representing
multiple things the company explained
given that built in multiplayer support
is a well-understood concept and more of
a normal expectation these days there
isn't as much need to maintain a
separate identity for what is
essentially our networking technology
Konami and kajima have had a strained
relationship to say the least and now
Kojima has weighed in on canalis new
metal gear game metal gear survive metal
gear survive features multiplayer
stealth and zombies Kadima with a little
thrown by that last one telling IGN the
Metal Gear games are about political
fiction and espionage where does on
these fit in with that he added if I'd
worked on the game it would have had mex
in it metal gear survive is Joanne on
Xbox ps4 and PC next year the game set
in the same universe as Metal Gear Solid
5 and takes place after the events of
ground zeroes the battlefield 1 beta has
prompted a bunch of tweaks based on fan
feedback and here's what's changing guys
have said that from now on in conquest
mode both capturing objectives and
getting kills will contribute toward the
final score of the match originally only
capturing and holding points would
matter at the
into the match with the winning team
holding the maximum number of points the
developer are also planning to tweak the
rush mode although exactly how wasn't
specified on top of that there will be
changes made to multiplayer balancing
particularly revolving around
overpowered horses and vehicles finally
a battle mode for Pokemon go has been
teased Pokemon company CEO tsunekazu
ishihara told the Wall Street Journal
that niantic labs are taking the time
releasing new features for Pokemon go so
they don't overwhelm newcomers he
explained battling is a category that we
do best at pokemon after all it's
important to really carefully consider
any feature that may increase the
difficulty and raise the barrier to
entry for more casual users last week a
buddy system was introduced as niantic
have said they plan on exploring
multiplayer further as well as a trading
system this week on site we check out
the new mex of titanfall to talk about
our impressions of serrana and compare
the ps4 to the ps4 slim that is
everything I've got for you this week
ado let me know what mattered to you
down in that comment section and I will
see you again on Monday